the general election in Bangladesh is
just few days away but there are hardly
any signs of mass relies or campaigning
except by the governing parties and the
people's reaction in the streets are
mixed the government doesn't need the
general masses for the last 15 years we
have not been able to credibly cast our
votes why is that don't you think we
have the desire to participate in the
voting process our votes are cast by
others the main opposition party says
millions of its members are facing a
government Crackdown and more than
20,000 have been in jail since late
October there is very little enthusiasm
in the street the main opposition party
and its allies are boycotting the poll
as many feel the incumbent governing
party is all set to win a fourth
straight term without much of a
contest the opposition's key demand is
that the election be held under a
caretaker Administration but the
government has rejected that the
opposition Alliance says it will stay on
the streets until this government is
ousted they have already executed the
election process weeks ago by publicly
determining the person who is going to
be the Member of Parliament from
whichever sits this has been decided not
in The Ballot Box but sitting in the
capital in the office of the highest
executive of the country this is the
paradox during her 15 years in power
prime minister shik Hina has been
credited with turning around the economy
and her supporters are betting on her
economic success H says she wants the
January 7 national election to be free
fair and
neutral we have secured people's right
to vote through struggle and movement
they think they will be able to take
those rights away and stop election
process but they don't have that courage
nor will they succeed in doing so
some analysts say without the Bangladesh
nationalist party and other opposition
groups taking part the election may not
meet legal requirements and many in the
global community may question its
credibility tan chadri Al jazer
Daka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer